>>> THE FATHER/SON RELATIONSHIP
IS ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
BONDS IN THE WORLD, BUT WE ALL
KNOW TALKING TO YOUR SON ISN'T
ALWAYS EASY, WHAT'S THAT?
>> ONE OF MY INVENTIONS.
>> SURE.
>> BUT NOW EVERY FATHER CAN
BREAK THROUGH TO HIS SON
USING --
THE FATHER/SON PODCASTING
MICROPHONE.
WITH THE FATHER/SON PODCASTING
MICROPHONE, YOU AND YOUR SON CAN
START TO HAVE REAL MEANINGFUL
CONVERSATIONS.
>> TODAY, I AM JOINED BY MY
CO-HOST, MY SON.
>> IT'S GREAT TO BE HERE, DAD.
>> DAD AND SON CAN FINALLY OPEN
UP TO EACH OTHER USING THE
COMFORTING CADENCE AND STRUCTURE
OF A PODCAST.
>> I'D SAY MY DAD'S DISTANT.
>> IT'S TOUGHT.
IT'S TOUGH.
YOU KNOW?
THIS NOTEBOOK, YOU CAN READ
ABOUT BEING A DAD.
>> ACTUALLY, THERE ARE SEVERAL.
>> A PODCAST IS A GREAT CHANCE
FOR FATHER AND SON TO GET RAW,
CONFESSIONAL, AND UNFILTERED.
>> I GUESS LOOKING BACK ON MY
LIFE SO FAR I'VE DONE EVERYTHING
IN ORDER TO GAIN MY DAD'S
APPROVAL.
>> BUT SOMETIMES THINGS GET TOO
REAL.
LUCKILY YOU CAN ALWAYS SHIFT
GEARS WITH A QUICK COMMERCIAL.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT I'D DO?
SQUARESPACE.
>> YOU WANT TO MAKE A BEAUTIFUL
WEBSITE IN NO TIME?
SQUARESPACE HAS YOU COVERED.
>> CHOOSE FROM HUNDREDS OF
STUNNING TEMPLATES, OR START
FROM SCRATCH.
AND OUR LISTENERS CAN GET
STARTED FOR FREE WITH PROMO CODE
#SONLOVEDAD.
>> YOU NAILED THAT KIDDO.
>> WITH A FATHER/SON PODCAST,
YOUR CONVERSATIONS CAN BE
DIVIDED INTO EQUALLY DIGESTIBLE
SEGMENTS.
>> WELL, IT TURNS OUT
VASECTOMIES DON'T ALWAYS TAKE,
AND THAT WRAPS UP THIS WEEK'S
EDITION OF FAMILY SECRETS.
>> AND WITH THIS ATTACHABLE
ADJUSTABLE MIC STAND, INVITE
SPECIAL GUESTS.
>> TOM AS YOUR OLD MAN.
>> I HAVE BEEN TAKING A LITTLE
BIT OF HGH.
>> THE FATHER/SON PODCASTING
MICROPHONE JUST HAS TO GET YOU
THROUGH THREE AWKWARD YEARS
BEFORE YOU CAN START DRINKING
TOGETHER.